para responder rápidamente a una posible amenaza.
Pero hay un problema con esta respuesta,
y es que, puede ser sobreactivada.
Si hago frente a estos factores estresantes en mi día a día,
especialmente en un periodo largo,
mi sistema puede sobrecargarse.
Así, si esta respuesta se produce pocas veces,
es súper necesaria para mi bienestar y supervivencia.
Pero si ocurre muy a menudo,
puede hacer que enferme.
Cada vez son más los estudios que investigan
la relación entre el estrés crónico y la enfermedad.
Algunas enfermedades coronarias e incluso el cáncer
muestran una relación con el estrés.
Y esto es porque, con el tiempo,
una gran activación del estrés
puede interferir en los procesos corporales que me mantienen sana.
Bien, imaginemos por un momento que estuviera embarazada.
¿Qué haría ese tipo de estrés
especialmente durante mi embarazo?
¿Qué tipo de impacto tendría
en la salud del feto en desarrollo?
Probablemente, no se sorprenderán si digo
que ese tipo de estrés durante el embarazo no es bueno.
Puede provocar un parto muy prematuro
porque, básicamente, el estrés comunica
que el vientre ya no es un lugar seguro para el bebé.
El estrés en el embarazo está relacionado
con la presión arterial alta
y el bajo peso del niño al nacer,
y puede iniciar una cascada de problemas de salud
que hacen que el parto sea mucho más peligroso
tanto para la madre como para el hijo.
Bueno, el estrés en nuestro estilo de vida actual
es una experiencia universal, ¿verdad?
Quizás nunca estén aquí para dar una charla TED Talk,
pero sí harán frente a una presentación en el trabajo,
una pérdida de trabajo repentina,
un importante examen,
un conflicto acalorado con un familiar o amigo.
Pero eso se convierte en un tipo de estrés que experimentamos,
y, que seamos capaces de relajarnos durante suficiente tiempo
para que nuestros cuerpos trabajen correctamente,
depende bastante de cómo somos.
Hay, además, un creciente volumen de investigaciones
que revela que las personas que experimentan más discriminación
son más propensas a gozar de una salud pobre.
Incluso la amenaza de discriminación
como preocuparte si te para la policía cuando vas conduciendo,
puede tener un impacto negativo en la salud.
El Dr. David Williams, profesor de Harvard,
pionero en las herramientas que han demostrado estos vínculos,
asegura que los grupos más marginados de la sociedad
experimentan más discriminación y más impacto en la salud.
He estado interesada en estas cuestiones casi una década.
Empecé a interesarme por la salud materna
cuando un fallo en mi recorrido preanestésico
me llevó a buscar un camino,
a buscar otras formas de ayudar
a las personas embarazadas.
Me hice comadrona-doula,
una persona inexperta entrenada para ayudar durante el embarazo y el parto.
Y, como soy latina y hablante de español,
en mi primer voluntariado como comadrona
en un hospital público de Carolina del Norte,
vi claramente cómo el racismo y la clase
afectaban a las experiencias
de las mujeres a las que asistí.
Si echamos un vistazo a las estadísticas
de los índices de enfermedad
durante el embarazo y el parto,
vemos claramente el patrón delineado por el doctor Williams.
Las mujeres afroamericanas en general
tiene una experiencia totalmente diferente
a la de las mujeres blancas
cuando se trata de si sus bebés nacen sanos.
En algunas partes del país, como el Sur Profundo,
la tasa de madres y niños muertos por mujeres negras
se aproxima a los índices de las mujeres del África subsahariana.
En estas mismas comunidades,
las tasas de mujeres blancas es casi nula.
Incluso nacionalmente, las mujeres negras
son cuatro veces más propensas a morir durante el embarazo y el parto
que las mujeres blancas.
Cuatro veces más propensas a morir.
También es dos veces más probable que sus hijos mueran
antes del primer año de vida
comparados con los niños blancos,
y de dos a tres veces más propensos
a nacer muy prematuros o con muy poco peso,
una señal de desarrollo insuficiente.
Además, es probable las indígenas
sufran más estos problemas
que las mujeres blancas,
porque son grupos de latinas.
Durante mi última década como comadrona
me hice periodista y bloguera,
he estado intentando dar la voz de alarma
por lo diferente que es la experiencia de las mujeres de color,
y, especialmente, de las mujeres negras,
cuando se trata del embarazo y del parto en EE. UU.
Pero al hablar a la gente de estas estadísticas atroces,
me topo, normalmente, con una presunción
de que es o por la pobreza o la falta de acceso a cuidados.
Pero resulta que nada de esto cuenta la historia completa.
Incluso las mujeres negras de clase media
obtienen peores resultados
que las mujeres blancas de clase media homólogas.
La diferencia se amplia entre este grupo.
Y mientras el acceso a los cuidados
sigue siendo un problema,
hasta las mujeres de color que reciben
los recomendados cuidados prenatales
siguen sufriendo por esos índices.
Y por eso, si volvemos al camino
de la discriminación para intensificar la mala salud
y si empezamos a dibujar un cuadro
en el que la gente de color pueda saber qué es lo real:
el racismo puede enfermarnos.
¿Les sigue pareciendo una exageración?
Pensemos esto: las inmigrantes,
especialmente, negras y latinas,
gozan actualmente de mejor salud
que cuando llegaron a EE. UU.
Pero, durante su estancia en ese país,
lo peor de sus vidas ha pasado ya.
Las personas que, como yo, nacen en EE. UU.
de padres cubanos inmigrantes,
son, de hecho, más propensas a tener peor salud
que cuando nacieron mis abuelos.
Es lo se conoce como "la paradoja de los inmigrantes",
y esto además ilustra
que hay algo en el ambiente de EE. UU.
que nos hace enfermar.
Pero la cuestión es esta:
este problema, este racismo hacia la gente de color
pero, especialmente a las mujeres y bebés negros, es amplio.
Podría pasar todo el tiempo hablándoles de esto,
pero no lo haré, porque quiero asegurarme
de darles una solución.
Y la buena noticia es que esta solución no es muy cara
no requiere ningún tratamiento farmacológico
ni nuevas tecnologías.
Esta solución se llama: "El método J. J."
Conozcan a Jennie Joseph.
Es una matrona de Orlando, en la zona de Florida,
que ha asistido a embarazadas durante una década.
En lo que ella señala como clínicas de fácil acceso,
Jennie y su equipo proporcionan cuidados prenatales
a casi 600 mujeres a año.
Sus clientes, la mayoría de ellas
negras, haitianas y latinas,
asisten en el hospital local.
Pero, al proporcionar ayuda prenatal accesible y respetuosa,
Jennie ha logrado algo increíble:
casi todas sus clientes dan a luz
a bebés saludables y nacidos a término.
Su método es aparentemente sencillo.
Jennie dice que todas sus consultas empiezan en recepción.
Cada miembro del equipo y, cada momento que una mujer pasa en su clínica,
es tan servicial como posible.
No se rechaza a nadie por falta de recursos.
El método J. J trata de que funcionen los fondos
sin importar las dificultades.
No se castiga a nadie por acudir más tarde a las citas.
No se menosprecia ni se subestima a nadie.
La sala de espera de Jennie en la consulta es más el salón de tu tía que una clínica.
Ella llama a este espacio "sala enmascarada".
Con las sillas de felpa dispuestas en forma de círculo,
las mujeres esperan su consulta
charlando de una en una con un educador personal
o en un grupo de clases prenatales.
Cuando finalmente se las vuelve a llamar para sus consultas,
las reciben Alexis o Trina,
dos de las asistentes sanitarias de Jennie.
Ambas son jóvenes, afroamericanas y madres.
Su acercamiento es relajado y amable.
Durante una consulta, vi que
Trina hablaba con una pronto futura mamá joven
mientras le medía la presión arterial.
Esta madre latina había tenido problemas
para comer debido a las náuseas.
Mientras Trina desinflaba el esfigmomanómetro,
le dijo: "Vamos a ver si podemos cambiar tu prescripción, ¿vale?
Nosotros no podemos tenerte sin comer".
Ese "nosotros" es un aspecto crucial en el método de Jennie.
Ve al personal como parte de un equipo que,
en la vida de la mujer y su familia,
tiene un objetivo;
conseguir que la mamá llegue a término con un bebé saludable.
Jennie dice que Trina y Alexis
son su modelo de centros de cuidados
y que su papel como asistente es solo un apoyo a su trabajo.
Trina pasa gran parte del día con el móvil
mensajeándose con las clientes sobre este tipo de cosas.
Una mujer la mensajeó para ver
si el medicamento que le recetaron en el hospital
era bueno durante el embarazo.
La respuesta fue "no".
Otra mujer le envió fotos de un bebé nacido con la ayuda de Jennie.
Por último, cuando las llaman para ver a la asistente,
ya se les ha medido el peso en la sala de espera
y se les ha hecho el test de orina en el baño.
Esto es una gran salida del método médico tradicional
porque otorga responsabilidad e información
en manos de la mujer.
Así, más que un entorno médico que debería reprenderle
por no seguir las recomendaciones de los asistentes
(un ambiente siempre disponible para mujeres de bajos ingresos),
el método de Jennie consiste en ayudar tanto como posible.
Y esta ayuda proporciona un colchón crucial
debido al estrés por el racismo y por la discriminación
que sufren estas mujeres cada día.
Pero hay algo aun mejor en el método de Jennie:
es increíblemente exitoso.
¿ Recuerdan que en las estadísticas de las que hablé
las mujeres negras eran más propensas al parto prematuro,
a dar a luz a bebés con bajo peso
e incluso a morir por las complicaciones del embarazo y el parto?
Bien, el método J. J. casi ha eliminado estos problemas
empezando por lo que Jennie llama "bebés delgados".
Ha sido capaz de conseguir que casi todas sus clientes
lleguen a término
con bebés tan sanos y regordetes como este.
(Audiencia): ¡Ay!
(Miriam Zoila Pérez): Es una niña
de una cliente de Jennie
nacida el pasado junio.
Una demografía similar a la de las mujeres de la zona de Jennie
que dieron a luz en el mismo hospital que sus clientes
fueron tres veces más propensas al parto
de un bebé saludable por debajo del peso.
Jennie está avanzando en lo que que ha visto durante décadas
como un problema casi inextricable.
Alguno de Uds. estará pensando
que toda esta atención una a una que precisa el método J. J.
debe ser muy cara de escalar.
Bien, pues se equivocan.
La visita a la clínica no es el centro del método de Jennie
y es por una buena razón.
Estas visitas son caras y para preservar su método
visita a muchas clientes para cubrir sus costos.
Pero Jennie no tiene que pasar excesivo tiempo con cada mujer
si cada miembro del equipo puede proporcionar ayuda, información
y cuidados necesarios.
Se cree que lo bueno del método de Jennie
es que puede aplicarse a cualquier ámbito de cuidados médicos.
Es una revolución de los cuidados que está esperando suceder.
Estos problemas que estoy compartiendo con Uds. son importantes.
Proceden de largas historias de racismo y clasismo,
de una sociedad basada en razas y en la estratificación social.
Encierran mecanismos psicológicos complejos
con la intención de protegernos,
de que, cuando nos sobreestimulemos, enfermemos.
Pero si algo he aprendido de mi trabajo de comadrona
es que un poco de apoyo incondicional
puede conducir a un largo camino.
La historia ha demostrado que la gente es increíblemente fuerte,
y que, aunque no podamos erradicar el racismo
o el estrés que nos pasa factura por la noche,
podemos crear un entorno que actúe de colchón
para la experiencia de la gente de color en su día a día.
Y durante el embarazo,
la mediadora puede ser una herramienta increíble
para cambiar el impacto del racismo
en las generaciones futuras.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)